what's the longest time you've gone
between auditions
oh wow um
months months
how is that for you
it's um demoralizing it's demoralizing
it's hard to keep up your enthusiasm and
your
joie de vivre about what you're doing
when you're only getting into the rooms
maybe once every
one or two or three months
and i don't know if there's a way around
that other than to not let that define
who you are as a person
i mean if you're not auditioning and you
and your reaction to that is to just
stay at home
and turn on old tv shows and
you know cry about not auditioning
you know i don't think that really
serves to help the situation at all
um and and i used to do that of course
everybody
you you're an actor you want to be
acting you want to be
given the opportunity to act and if
you're not getting those things it's
depressing and discouraging
instead though i mean and i still go
through those periods where there
are you know feasts and famine times
um and when things aren't as
as fast as they have been in the past
you know i just
i go out and do something i enjoy i find
some other thing to occupy my
mind one of the best things to do is to
go help somebody else
because when i'm thinking about somebody
else and helping them
what am i not thinking about myself and
my own problems
so i really strongly recommend that
in addition to you know whatever
interests outside of acting that you
have
throw in some sort of volunteer work
i i i can't tell you how
much that's benefited me and and gotten
my
gotten me out of my own head sometimes
which is the worst place to be sometimes
just the worst um
and those times will pass they always
have
they always will of course you always
think with every job
that it's the last job you'll ever have
you'll never work again and
uh the truth is i've been doing this a
long time
and i have been provided for by the
universe
through all of it and there's no reason
to think that that won't continue to
happen
for as long as it's supposed to happen
so
i'm content with that and if things
are a little slow i'll just go off and
do something else that i enjoy
you